JAMES GOES BACKDOOR, INSIDE,
BANKS IT HOME.
>> Jeff: I LIKE HOW THEY'RE
USING LeBRON JAMES AS A SCREENER
AND A ROLLER.
HE IS SO DIFFICULT TO HANDLE
ROLLING TO THE RIM.
>> Jeff: NOW HE HAS TIED KOBE,
AS BLAKE GRIFFIN MISSES THAT
ONE.
JAMES SPINS, KICKS IT OUT,
WESTBROOK.
RIGHT BACK INTO JAMES -- AND
ONTO THE FREE-THROW LINE, WHERE
HE'S OVERALL 12 POINTS.
>> Jeff: WELL, THEY SWITCHED THE
PICK AND ROLL AND THEN JAMES
JUST DISCARDS BRUCE BROWN AND AN
EASY LAY-UP OFF A NICE PASS BY
WESTBROOK.
>> Mike: LeBRON JAMES WILL TURN
37 YEARS OLD THIS COMING
THURSDAY.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT IT, 37,
19th YEAR IN THE LEAGUE.
NOW HE IS THE ALL-TIME LEADING
SCORER ON CHRISTMAS.
AND THE NUMBERS HE'S PUTTING UP,
I SAY 19th YEAR, ADD ANOTHER
COUPLE OF YEARS WITH ALL THE
PLAYOFF GAMES, THE NUMBERS HE'S
PUTTING UP RIGHT NOW, THIS LAST
12, 13-GAME SURGE, IT'S
EXTRAORDINARY.
>> Jeff: HIS WHOLE CAREER HAS
BEEN EXTRAORDINARY.
THE WAY HE'S SUSTAINED
GREATNESS -- I'M SURE THERE ARE
SOME THINGS, AS STANLEY JOHNSON
RUNS TO THE OTHER END, CALLED
FOR A FOUL.
>> Mike: THAT'S GOING TO BE THE
FIFTH TEAM FOUL.